pour une même cible
ça va être un bon
bon pour nous mêmes et toutes et tous
pourquoi la femme à la mémoire de la
bauma le matin même
tu vois ça comme un démon me base pas
eu lieu
embarrassé
touba l'approcher
israël gens cultivent les piments et le
riz dans la vallée de l'artibonite le
grenier alimentaire d'haïti
il possède quatre carreau un peu plus
de 5 hectares de terre mais sans canaux
d'irrigation adéquate il dépend de la
pluie pour ses récoltes
trop de précipitation ou pas assez il
peut tout perdre
il a travaillé dur il n'a pas de
machinerie pas d'engrais non plus il
n'en a pas les moyens
néanmoins le plus jeune fils du
dialogue
le passé
la sotiba laval
ce n'est pas facile pour les
agriculteurs les banques haïtiennes
n'ont pas l'habitude de leur prêter de
l'argent
ils doivent faire appel à des prêteurs
plus serein
l'affairé se tasse un peu amer
le producteur
un temps de crise
mohammed fathallah un garage ça fait
une maladie à la fin mais les attaques
mortelles
sa fête des enfants qui vont à
l'école
depuis quatre ans développement
international des jardins en
collaboration avec le gouvernement
canadien
s'est associé à des institutions
financières locales pour leur apprendre
à faire du micro crédit agricole
mais attention les taux d'intérêt sont
élevés
entre deux et 3 8% par mois
son épouse l'a trouvé de 5% pour un
mois
ça peut paraître élevée chez nous
on sait qu'on sera ponctuée si on
analyse la rentabilité de production
l'emprunt a été capable de le payer
pas de temps mort marque
ces producteurs est un bon client d'une
coopérative financière partenaire de
desjardins sans quoi la victime
treiber près de cinq heures à 51 ans
il en est à son troisième prêt un
montant de 8000 $
là pas de quoi la part d'hekla
notez tout été défaits l'été
bah pourquoi le relais
cette date du moyen-âge
passant ça
c'est ça que ça ne pas avoir déposé
à la barre d'après les témoins les
plus abordables et simples machines en
acheter avec machines à remonter à 27
5 me de dettes une cravate ou l'autre on
ne pourra pas reprocher au bord de l'eau
pour continuer à travailler
une piste
maintenant vous êtes abonné au site
m
la dépêche de l'afp
la part de marché des droits carbone
riches
en fait que croître
à la plage
mais l'expérience n'est pas sans risque
israël genre aussi a pu bénéficier
d'un microcrédit
à ses dépens
et aller allumer
et le maire
problème se pose aux bleus leur la fed
cadettes
l'hôtel muna déplore hélène leduc
des vagues de dix mètres
c'est de la loi de la loi de robien
on va là-bas pour gagner les tableaux
les riziculteurs haïtiens font pas
faillite inégal
une croix des bossales le plus grand
marché de port au prince le riz
d'artibonite trop coûteux
et boudée par les clients
non non non
jean laverdière
l'ouragan irène
le maire
il est aujourd'hui près de 80% du prix
cacher que les haïtiens qui étaient
portés du riz américain surtout de
produits plus grande échelle et
fortement subventionné
qui se vante de 30 à 50 % moins cher
que le riz local
l'attaqué des attaques placées
charles suffrages dirige une association
paysanne
il se désole pour autant d'argent pour
des milliards de dollars pour la
reconstruction elle était très
agressive et surtout dans la capitale et
déjà surpeuplés plutôt qu'en
régions du pays une occasion ratée
selon lui de retenir les haïtiens dans
les campagnes où les gens vivent mieux
pour toi je pense que c'est quand même
un bta l'année
- d'échapper le total de la période
pour donner une idée
elle n'a pas donné son accord
la pureté des médias au clip tourné
à la période pour lui pour moi ces
développements
et là-bas était comble
pour moi cela prouvait surnombre
pour le salon accès nous sommes à la
production
une base sociale
loubier
le parc tout n'est pas tant que ça
nous nous sommes rendus plus loin encore
dans l'artibonite une terre de montagnes
et des rivières ou l'automne les plus
abondantes
les villages du reste du pays
oxfam-québec s'y applique depuis des
années comme ici après berlin
dans de petites initiatives locales pour
aider justement les familles à rester
à la campagne
pourquoi maintenant à la dernière
c'est souvent parce qu'il y avait la
fibre végétale
des patins
pourront faire éditer promesses
et on était tout petit déjà à brno
et parfois leurs pratiques été
parmi les autres partenaires aucune
difficulté
derrière toute cette scène
elle a profité pour nous
aujourd'hui stéphane près par du sirop
de tamarin une gauche dans la pulpe
acidulées et qui teaser en cuisine
elle transforme aussi que d'autres
fruits selon les saisons
il ya beaucoup de défis bien
eh oui quoique le monde les dernières
années ces machines problèmes
principaux a relevé il m'a tapoté au
sénat on est la meilleure cote vous
roulez sur le maire
au ps aux bêtes noires
en effet les jeunes
l'eiopa papa d'aurélia places payées
déjà de même cinq femmes sont
partenaires dans cette petite
coopérative
elle se verser un salaire de 125 gourdes
par jour 3 $ 30 c'est moins que le
salaire minimum
mais pour monique charretier veulent
cela vaut la peine de marcher de trois
heures pour se rendre à l'atelier et
revenir à la tombée de la nuit
à l'occasion il faut quand même que
celle que l'on trouve des essais en vol
et quang ninh
un mail il ya un mois a été meilleure
que la veille leur parler en fait pas
peur elle étend la possibilité ou
ailleurs
pour l'occasion pour thomas et les
marines ont par rapport à l'ancienne
notre application iphone que ces gens
ont compris qu'il avait fait une
formation ces agissements ont contraint
de quitter il faut marquer
charles suffrages lui je souhaiterais
qu'on investisse davantage dans la
production nous l'aimions père
pour moi c'est la base
production
dans les canalisations huot il fallait
que ça le vélo pour le pont du climat
teigneux
des productions quel matériel pour le
pôle %
pour le conseiller qui est expédié un
but est bien de l'eau
pour shi ce cas présent le programme de
prêts l'école de des jardins apèrs
mis à huit mille agriculteurs de
l'artibonite
d'obtenir du financement
des débuts modestes mais prometteur
on parle d'environ un million et demi de
retard dans cette quête
il n'est qu'à ses débuts
en attendant à l'intérieur de la
coopérative secoue la ville ce mur est
tapissé d avis de recherche des mauvais
payeurs
bientôt la photo d'israël gens
devraient s'y retrouver puisqu'il est en
défaut de paiement
hatoyama lame d'eau google panda aulas
deux poids deux mesures heyer
dans certains de ses coûts le groupe
recherché par les autorités
il se cache pendant la journée asamoah
gomez
en salle mais la balle passait les
fêtes ça me fait quand même plus haut
ça me dégoûte
la loi haïtienne prévoit qu'on ne peut
pas arrêter une personne après le
coucher du soleil
à moins qu'elle ne soit prise en
flagrant délit
alors israël compte bien profiter de
cette clause pour se cacher le temps
qu'il faudra
ça
et ben moi jacky brovelli pas jeter on
paie les a pas qu'à moi et j'ai
edel a dit apa - alger
même si on joue on pourra voir le jour
dileita élevé si le pays a appris la
pana mardi prochain premier prix la ruse
et de problèmes légaux le budget pub
la voie est libre mais moi j'ai pu dire
plus la pluie de problèmes de dos t la
prison deux problèmes le serbe a pas
besoin
ma parole à mamadou diabaté bêh
allemagne google
et pour poursuivre la réflexion sur le
sujet on voit notamment un très bon en
photoreportage sur l'agriculture en
haïti
plus à l'est à consulter notre dossier
où elle à l'adresse que vous voyez à
l'écran